ha-ha-ha-ha
はじめーーーん！　ドン・キホーテの物全部ーー買ってみてそれ企画にしてーーーー！(読み上げ)
許してくださいよっ！無理！！！！
こんにちは！料理する気のはじめしゃちょーです！
みなさん、パン、好きですか？
僕は基本コンビニでしか飯を食わないんで、あのーコンビニのパンはいつも食べてるんですけど
最近のコンビニのパン、ほんまに美味しいで
ほんと最近のコンビニのパン美味しすぎて
あのーとりあえず、全種類買ってきました
め、めっちゃあるやーん
整地！はあああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ！！！！！！！！！！！
袋、外れろおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
というわけでこちらにあるのが、ローソンに
僕が見た感じ売ってたパン全部買ってきました
コンビニのパン全種類です。もう、なんか、ああああああああ卵コロッケパンとか♡
やば、もうパン屋さんやん。菓子パンから惣菜パン。
もうほんとにパン屋かよｗみたいな
金黒の半分半分や（？）おっとっと。
ありとあらゆるパンっぽいものを全部買ってきたんですけども
コンビニのパンって、美味しくないものがないんですよ
僕が食ってきた限り、美味しくないものはないので
これ全部混ぜて食うと、美味しいんじゃねえかっていう単純な
僕の発想のもと、今回は動画を、進めていかせささせてください。
ちゃんと食いますんで！ちゃんと食うんで！俺だけじゃ無理だから、後輩たちとちゃんと食うんで！
全部混ぜ合わせた味を僕は感じてみたいんすよ！
年明けに。
ではいこう（きりっ
何種類あるんだろう？いち、に、、、、、、
５０くらいかな？だいたい５０種類のパンがあります
この５０種類くらいのパンを一切れずつ組み合わせて
混ぜて食うと、果たしてなんの味になるのか。
コンビニのパンってねぇ、よぉく考えて作られてるんですよー！
もう計算だてられて美味しく作られてるんで
これを全部混ぜて食うと、美味しいことは間違いないと思うので
今回やってみようと思います！
ちなみにコンビニのパンでよく食べるのは・・・・
ダイエットしてる時はこの米粉パン、いつも食べてましたね
これすごいダイエットに効くみたいです
最近だとコンビニにチュロスがあるんですよね
あと、一時期何故かこのカレーパンにハマってた時期もありましたね。あと卵パンね。
これ無理だな（小声
あぶな。
さあ果たしてどんな味になるのでしょうか
とりあえず一切れずつ集めていきます！
やべやべ、なくなっちゃいそう
はいでは一切れずつもらっていきましょう
まぁとりあえずパンといったらこれでしょう。焼きそばパン！
まじほんと微量でいいんだよな
５０個もあると多分すごい量になっちゃうんで
めっちゃわずかにもらっていきます
ヘンナノ。
ヨクアルヤツ。
なんか高校の時よく食ってた
チョコチップスティック。
板チョコ乗ってるやつ。これちょーうめぇんだよなぁ
板チョコをちゃんと入れてあげたいところではあるなぁ
どんどん細かくしていきます
卵パン！
チョコチップメロンパン！
ウインナーのやつ。
（包丁が落ちる音）
あ！あ！！あ！！！
やばい！！やばい！！！！
血が出た！！血が出た！！！血が…まぁいっか。
皆さん見ましたか？こういう風に包丁で遊んでると、怪我するんですよ
気を付けてくださいね
シーチキン…マヨネーズみたいなやつだ。
長めのカレーパン。クロワッサン！チュロス！
色が…………………………………………うんｔ
小豆と、マーガリンの入ってるやつ
チョココロネ。ホットドックっぽいパン。スティックパン！！チョコクロワッサン！バターロール！
ぽいっ。わー！チョコチョコのチョコのパンだ（？）
ということはこっちはクリーム確定演出や（？）
ダークネスメロンパン！はいっ！！！
できましたー！ローソンのパンを一切れずつ
全部集めたものです
これをこれからどうしようかと言いますと
このままだと、まだパンではないので
これをひとまとまりにしていこうと思います♪
♪ED曲♪